hasta ahora siete de los nueve
representantes a la cámara demócratas
que están acusando al presidente de
trump de insurrección presentaron pues
este argumento de que fueron sus
palabras las que derivaron en los actos
violentos del 6 de noviembre fue de tim
james king eric software joaquín castro
stage y plaskett mcclain bin y joe news
que presentaron vídeos trinos audios
entrevistas pruebas de que el 6 de enero
no fue un hecho aislado sino que las
palabras de donald trump incitaron a
esta violencia y que el ex presidente no
hizo mucho al respecto para parar la
violencia que en contraparte lo que hizo
fue consolar a los simpatizantes que
estaban cometiendo estos actos de
violencia me quedo con una frase del
representante de liu que dice que trump
se quedó sin opciones no violentas para
tratar de quedarse en el poder y por eso
invitó a sus simpatizantes el 6 de enero
para tratar de frenar la consolidación
la confirmación de joe biden como
presidente en el congreso lo que viene
ahora entonces
pues que finalicen estas horas que
tienen los demócratas para presentar sus
argumentos y después entonces será la
contraparte los abogados de donald trump
los que tengan sus 16 horas para
presentar su defensa y estaremos atentos
cristóbal a lo que ocurra durante ese
proceso pero además fiscales del estado
de georgia abrir una investigación penal
también cuando al expresidente de trump
por lo que ellos consideran un intento
suyo de influir en los resultados de las
elecciones en ese estado de que lo que
son exactamente cristóbal
claro esa nueva fiscal fanny willis de
el condado de fruto en en georgia que es
uno de los condados que más aportó votos
para ese estado que ganó el presidente
yo bailé en la que manda una carta a
autoridades y líderes locales diciendo
que empezará esta investigación para
pues no solamente revelar como él
preside el ex presidente don otro trató
de influir en esta elección en ese
estado al llamar al entonces secretario
del estado pidiéndole que reversar a los
votos y pidiéndole también que
encontrara algunos votos para que fuera
donald trump el que ganara los votos
electorales de ese estado concretamente
esta investigación le pide a los
fiscales que investiguen la solicitud de
fraude a ser testimonios falsos
violación por juramento conspiración y
amenazas y violencia contra autoridades
electorales locales